I don't know about this costume think
luck it'll work it has to if I have an
effective disguise I won't have to worry
about people finding out about me turn
down for what we're back louder with
better thrilled to have this next
guessing because I grew up on the guy ha
ha I want to geek out a little bit the
one and only Dean Cain is with us Dean
thank you for coming in sir uh Siva I
think you listen a roundabout way just
said I'm old
well not dancing around about way was
respectful yeah but I figure it's okay
because for those who are listening
terrestrially we're doing this extras
video cash you can listen to it lighter
with credit calm you look good so it
doesn't matter if you're off I'll take
that yeah yeah body sometimes betrays me
a little bit but but I'm hanging in
there
so deed you've been all over the media
funnily enough this week which is not
really why it initially reached out to
you we sort of connected last week and
then BOOM whirlwind because you were
friends with the American sniper right
mister I'm wearing a hat for right right
I can see that right there
yeah and not only that but of course
there's been a lot there have been a lot
of celebrities in the news Seth Rogen
Michael Moore talking out and you sent
Java the more tweet yourself what was it
that you sent to him well he said he was
taught that kites diapers were cowards
yeah and and the reality is I don't know
anybody who's less of a coward in the
world ever that I've ever met than Chris
Kyle so that ticked me off again Chris
is a good friend of mine he trained me
we were we were partners on stars earn
stripes we became great friends from
there and we were gonna stay friends for
ever and and I was just ticked off the
way I would be ticked off if you called
my brother a name I didn't like so I
sent back a lovely quick tweet and I
said something to the effects of call
Chris Kyle Chris Kyle coward to my face
and I think we'll see who a coward is it
was very playground rough but it came
out Roberts just it just came out well
here's my actually this is a genuine
question
okay and believe me I am NOT going to
judge you if you answer the way that I
pray to God you do let's say it actually
happens okay some parallel universe
Michael Moore is in a room with you I
don't know he's in a bar and you just
and he says okay you know what I'm gonna
go for it I'm gonna try and in triple
salchow stick the landing
Dean Cain your friend Chris Kyle is a
coward okay would you bring him bodily
harm uh have I had a drink or two yet I
do I mean that dependent let's say
sometimes I pull that trigger a lot
faster a couple drinks that trigger just
gets pulled right away bang uh I mean it
would be look what I like to give him a
smack for that if he looked me in the
eye as a man and said that sure I'd love
to be on an elevator with him and have
him say that right well with no camera
wait a minute you want the Ray Rice
robot yeah and camera back it takes that
back not an elevator JZ Ray Rice though
right don't but us in an elevator but a
some place without a camera um yeah you
know it's hard you don't never you know
you know when something like that
happens you don't know how you really
react I mean I would I would maybe I'd
slap it yeah I would think an open palm
flat and he would tell me um you know as
well as anybody but you hit him open
father it's not right it's it's as hard
as anything whatever it was oops sorry
right you know the problem is though
he's so I mean I mean we've seen what
can happen when someone who is that in
that poor physical condition gets any
kind of stress applied to him you know a
slap could put him into a coma for 40
years again how many years have you
known Chris Kyle Lee you know American
sniper we we bet probably about I guess
there's about two and a half years ago
uh why do I said anything let's see he
was killed a year after the show and so
I met him on the show so I guess it's
2:30 for the time gets away from me
Stephen yeah thank you this old stuff is
really starting to tick oh come on stop
it yes okay so let me ask you something
here we're taught over timeout Chris
Kyle but let me switch topics and I do
this I know this is a risk now I I sort
as an actor and stand-up comic and no
matter what I do with kids probably your
son is 14 they know the show Arthur look
cartoon I did the voice of his best
friend the brain it was very out of
character that's what I was a method
actor I had to learn how to pretend to
be smart and people constantly bring it
up and I have other cast members who get
really mad about that I just think if
it's touched someone in a way that they
they still remember that good for them
when people bring up obviously Lois and
Clark because it's such a such an
American it's such an iconic show does
it bother you or you like I've got new
stuff for just go hey great let's sign
an autograph well you know one day Chris
Kyle showed up on the set of stars earn
stripes in a Superman s shirt right and
a little cape yeah and I whipped his ass
now that did I ahh he looked at house
liked him you look better debt than I
ever did mom said she's 14
she's 14 by Sharia grace of Allah she's
legal to be married that is Sharia by
the way oh